*sigh* This movie… doesn’t make sense.
This movie doesn’t make sen--
Welcome back to Things You Missed.
Last time we covered Pet Sematary -- this
time I’m taking on the movie-only sequel
Pet Sematary II.
The way the logo is animated calls back to
the blue light that shines from the Mic Mac
burial grounds in the first one, but the actual
tone of the movie does not remind of the first
one.
It opens on a Hollywood movie set where this
woman is reaching to open a coffin it seems
-- a little bit of a hint that maybe her coffin
is going to be pried open later on.
But before she can open it, this hand reaches
for her (as part of the horror movie they’re
filming), and later on we get a better look
at that prop.
It looks exactly like the hand that appeared
a couple years beforehand in IT.
I later found out that it actually is the
same exact prop, so props to them for reusing
that, pun intended.
Another possible Stephen King reference can
be seen on the slate, which displays the title
of this movie within the movie: Castle of
Terror.
It could be a reference to Castle Rock, which
is a location in Maine that shows up in a
bunch of Stephen King novels and later got
its own TV show.
Thirty-three takes?
Yikes.
Maybe Renee was lucky to have gotten the early
ticket off that set.
What I want to know is who saw this woman
getting electrocuted and decided, ‘you know
what?
I’m gonna knock over this 1K just to add
to the noise.'
We then meet Renee’s husband, who is a veterinarian,
which I found interesting because Louis, from
the first movie, specifically says that he’s
not a vet at one point.
“I'm trying to tell myself that I buried
him alive.
I’m not a vet.”
This kid has to make the decision to put down
his beloved dog -- and Dr. Mathews is faced
with a similar decision at the end of the
movie.
So then like 2 hours after the funeral of
his wife, Dr. Mathews is already checking
out his attractive young housekeeper.
If he had been able to keep his eyes off of
her, he would have noticed the name of the
moving company -- Mayflower.
Historically, the Mayflower was the name of
one of the ships that brought the first European
settlers to America.
These settlers ended up driving away the Native
American groups that already lived there -- and
this movie is basically about white settlers
defiling an ancient Indian burial ground.
But I’m with Dr. Mathews on this one, the
hot chick is much more interesting to look
it.
She almost gets killed by a box of Renee’s
stuff...
“Look out!
Look out!”
Which sets up her eventually later getting
killed by Renee herself.
Dr. Mathews’ son Jeff tags along as he goes
to work, where he basically sums up the entire
movie.
“This isn’t too bad.
It’s uh, pretty bad.”
For example here’s a newspaper from Coweta,
Georgia, where they filmed the movie even
though it’s supposed to take place in Maine.
The town sheriff brings his step-son to get
his dog Zowie checked out by the new doc,
even though he end up shooting the dog THE
VERY NEXT NIGHT.
“Come on Amanda, stop looking at me like
that, he’s had ample warning about that
dog!”
So what was the point of bringing him to the
vet if you wanted him dead?
I just don’t understand the logic there.
Also Jeff tries to bring his cat to school
and it gets taken by the bullies.
I only bring it up because I’ll probably
never get to use the work “catnap” again,
and because you might have missed this display
dedicated to Jeff’s mother.
I guess it makes sense that she’d be kind
of a hero in such a small town if she made
it as a B-list actress in Hollywood.
Also, when the bullies are running away you
can get a little glimpse of the mascot of
the Jr High school.
It’s the Lumberjacks, which may be another
reference to Native Americans vs European
settlers theme that I mentioned earlier.
During the bike chase that ensues, they ride
by the Creed house, even though it looks nothing
like the house from the first movie.
Then Jeff goes to look for the cat in a Pet
Sematary that looks nothing like the Pet Sematary.
Also, the deadfall looks nothing like the
deadfall from the first one.
It also doesn’t make sense how the main
bully, Clyde Parker, which is an excellent
bully name by the way, had time to hide the
cat all the way in the Pet Sematary, I mean
Jeff and the sheriff’s son, Drew, were on
his tail the entire time, like I don’t when
that happened.
But anyway, Jeff finds his cat, and he and
Drew bond over a mutual dislike for their
step-parents / sexy housekeeper basically
step-mom kind of thing.
“The first day of school is always the hardest.”
“You’re not my mother.”
*sad music*
Jeff and Drew go to bury Zowie.
At this point you shouldn’t be surprised
that it looks nothing like the burial ground
from the first one.
In the following scene we see the inside of
Drew’s room.
I’m guessing he’s supposed to be from
Seattle or something, because he’s got a
poster for SeaFair, which takes place in Seattle
and there’s a Mariners pennant near his
door.
This could also be part of the reason he and
Jeff become friends, both being transplants
from the West Coast, though it’s not explained
at all during the movie.
His parents are at the door to let him know
that Zowie is back, and his mom gives Dr.
Mathews a call to take a look at him.
While Zowie is staying at the Matthews’
house, he turns up in the middle of the night
in Jeff’s room looking all SCP-1471.
The next part takes place on Halloween, which
was good to see because the first Pet Sematary
movie skips over Halloween, but in the book
it’s actually an important scene where Jud
Crandall’s wife Norma has a heart attack
and Louis saves her life, an event that Jud
would later cite as part of the reason he
felt he had to help Louis revive his daughter’s
cat by introducing him to the Mic Mac burial
ground.
Clyde Parker gives everyone an IMDB summary
of the first movie in ghost-story form as
they sit around a fire at the Pet Sematary,
when the sheriff comes and breaks up the party
so he can punish his son with a little bit
of domestic violence, but Zowie comes to the
rescue and tears his freaking throat out.
This is where things just go off the rails.
Jeff and Drew have a sudden change of heart
and decide to bring the sheriff back using
the Mic Mac grounds.
He comes back as a much nicer guy for some
reason..?
I guess that’s what happens when the person
who dies is already more evil than The Wendigo.
Back in Dr. Mathews’s office, he get back
the results of Zowie’s blood test, which
say that the blood came from a dead animal
as the ironic “Natural Life Pet Products”
sign hangs over his head.
Yeah… there’s nothing natural about this
doggo’s life anymore.
Wait, wait, hold on right there.
Play that back.
Does he just start casually eating dog treats?
What is wrong with this guy?
I mean, I’ve accidentally eaten a dog treat
before and let me just say they’re not good.
Dr. Mathews discovers that Zowie has escaped
and stops by the school to go let Jeff and
Drew know.
Does anyone else thing these two deserve their
own 2000s Nickelodeon sitcom?
"Well I never thought..."
Dr. Mathews go to visit the former Ludlow
veterinarian, who has taken up taxidermy.
Sounds like the villain of a whole nother
horror movie.
But he goes to ask about the dead animal blood.
The old vet tells him this happened once before
with the Creed’s cat Church from the first
movie.
Church does go to the vet to get fixed, but
that’s before he died, and there’s no
indication of Louis taking him to the vet
after that.
The old vet does have a pair of antlers mounted
on his door, which could be this movie’s
tiny Wendigo reference, just like the mantle-piece
in Jud’s room was in the first one.
Meanwhile the sheriff isn’t trying to kill
anyone but he’s completely lost it.
Yeah.
While Jeff is over at Drew’s house for dinner,
Dr. Mathews sulks in grievance; watching movies
that his wife was in.
This is actually a real movie that the actress
who played Renee was in called Once Upon A
Time In America.
I’m kind of impressed they didn’t just
take the whole Bride of Chucky route and just
have Danlanne Fluegelle in the movie as herself.
The next day after Josh and... ohhhh...
I just did that...
The next day after Jeff and Drew get done
hanging out and being angsty, Drew notices
excellently named bully Clyde Parker coming
after his friend and performs one of the most
impressive athletic feats in cinema history.
Haha, the best part is that’s actually the
music.
Clyde has some weird fascination with bike
spoke related injuries…
"There was a little accident.
She was trying to get away.
Her head got caught in the spokes."
... and just before Jeff’s face gets chopped
up, he’s inexplicably saved by a zombie
sheriff.
Who then completely does a 180 and starts
killing everyone he sees.
I never claimed that this movie made sense.
He temporarily turns into Jack Torrance from
The Shining.
“I’m gonna bash your head in.”
“I’m just gonna bash your brains in.”
"****ing stupid!:
"Here's Johnny!"
"Mom!"
Hey, you know what’s strange?
In Pet Sematary, the road is constantly filled
with passing trucks.
In fact that’s kind of like a main point
of that movie.
But we’ve seen plenty of road shots, and
there hasn’t been one single tru-- oh wait.
I see what’s gonna happen.
*sad music*
So the sheriff decides to revive Clyde and
Renee for some reason -- I mean, he does explain
why he wants Renee, but at this point it really
just seems like he's doing random stuff.
The only thing I found that seem to kind of
explain his behaviour, is because the Wendigo
never actually appeared in the first movie,
it seems like the director Mary Lambert could
be going for a demonic possession type of
thing instead.
This cross that is usually upright in the
sheriff’s house is now inverted, and it
looks like he went a little crazy with the
chainsaw offscreen...
And the lawnmower?
I’m not sure if this is supposed to be a
reference or not, but the way Jeff is sitting
in this chair reminds me a lot of Claire from
Black Christmas.
This movie ends the same way as the first
one essentially, with all the zombies showing
up, and then dying in a fire.
Except this time the fire is started by the
zombies.
The sheriff goes through all this trouble
to bring these people back, and then they
basically just want to die again?
There’s a clear chance for Renee to escape
right here, but she just wants them to stay
with her as she burns in the fire.
So I’ll wrap up this video how I started
it by saying…
“This movie makes no sense!”
But we’re not done with Pet Sematary yet,
because the remake is coming out in just a
couple weeks so check out the video on the
left to hear about the complete history of
the Pet Sematary Wendigo and make sure you’re
subscribed to CZsWorld to hear about all the
things you might have missed in the 2019 Pet
Sematary, ring the deatbell for notifications
and I’ll see you in the next one.
Assuming we both survive.